how can we create online programs that
maybe aren't for full degrees but
there's still
skills based potentially certifications
that have the branding that are
recognized by employers there needs to
be a shift on the employer side to
accept these new types of trainings
tess manning thank you so much for
joining me on 20 minute leaders good
morning to you good evening to me how
are you
thanks michael doing well great to be
here and appreciate the invitation
i'm very very happy that you're here
because we're going to talk about one of
my favorite
markets and industries that
unfortunately i don't know nearly enough
as much as i should which is the
education space
and you have a really fascinating
trajectory all the way from from working
at a company like pluralsight
which which which i've used and many of
my friends use all the way to now being
a principal at the gsb
ventures and and and really focusing on
the education
sector and more deeply but in between
there were some other really incredible
things like doing an
mba at stanford helping teach classes at
stanford
and we have to get started with your fun
fact which is the fact that
you know you're a dancer at heart and
and you actually taught some hip hop and
and dance to some
people at stanford in the vc space
that's right that's right uh so while i
was at
gsb i was teaching a what turned into
a weekly hip hop dance class with one of
my classmates
to all of our class mates starting our
first year we have an end of the year
musical that is essentially a parody of
the gsb
and we roped in a lot of people to
perform that year
a lot of women and men who had never
danced before found out they had a love
and passion for dance in their late 20s
early 30s
was i was really inspired by that and so
my classmate and i started actually
teaching around the bay
and i think my favorite favorite uh
story
is that heidi royzen at threshold
ventures
came to class found out what we were
doing and she organized a group of
women and a few men and we taught them a
full three-minute dance over
the course of eight weeks and had a
final performance at the threshold
office which was incredible
unbelievable unbelievable so tess
walk me a little bit through your
journey eh why education
why stanford mba what's going on over
there
yes it's been an interesting journey so
i i
started my startup journey in new york i
had worked at a number of startups over
the course of
seven years before moving to um out to
the west coast for gsb
the first startup i actually worked at
was during college i was
an intern at one of the first companies
that was part of the first cohort of
tech stars in new york
and they were an education technology
company and this was back in
2011 and their vision was to democratize
you know access to knowledge on the web
and to help people
learn adult learners learn new topics in
a fun way
that that really resonated with me
because i was really passionate about
um economic development and helping
people all over the world find
opportunities which i think a lot of
people
you know have a similar mission when
they're in college but this really felt
like a viable way to do that so i was
really excited about the power of
technology and spreading education
had a few different companies that i
worked at before coming back full circle
to ed tech
had worked at two other startups in new
york that were both fast growth
learned kind of the ins and outs of lots
of different functions from
sales and account management to product
people operations recruiting really the
full gamut aside from
actually programming and designing and
uh and fell in love with working with
early stage startups
so right before i came to the gsb i
worked at a startup called indela
which at the time was a tiny talent
accelerator focused on high potential
young people in nigeria
and we were giving them six months of
full stack training for free
and then helping place them with with
long-term roles as distributed engineers
really inspiring life-changing for them
for us for the teams that they worked
with all over the world
um really demonstrated the power of
diverse teams and
and was is just an incredible win-win
all around
and and commercially viable as well so
that startup now
you know there are over 2000 engineers
there's series the company
really incredible and so i was excited
about that that business model so
coming to the gsb knew i wanted to stay
in edtech and workforce development
spent my summer at pluralsight uh right
after they had ipo'd
and then coming out of the gsb you know
had to
make that decision of going back to an
early stage company or
you know as fate would have it found out
that gsv ventures which is an
edtech venture fund uh that focuses on
early stage founders
was was hiring in tandem throwing their
um
their second fund and so uh the stars
kind of aligned and turns out
uh andala and pluralsight were both gsb
portfolio companies and
it felt like the right next step so i've
been here for about a year now
that that that's remarkable first of all
you know it sounds like over
over the course of of your of your
career i mean it's it's a formal career
and you're so young already
so it's hugely impressive but it's but
you know it sounds that in retrospect
it's pretty easy to draw the dots
and to and to see the this linear curve
but what was it a linear
career did you did you imagine when you
were in africa that you're going to be
in pluralsight to the gsb to gsv
what what was going on there no
absolutely not i mean it's it's
hilarious when i when i look at the
resumes of all my classmates at the gsb
and compare them with mine you know that
so many of them have stories that you
know they were
they were making um kind of you know
very conscious
calculated decisions every step of the
way and then they got to the gsb and
we're like oh my god what now
um so i was i've always been a bit like
oh my god what now
uh and then once i got to gsb i actually
had more clarity when i was
here on on what i wanted to do so coming
in i mean i might have been one of the
only people that
stuck to what i wrote in my essay you
know i wrote that i wanted to help
education technology companies
find viable business models because
historically it's been very difficult
right and
you can even see that on the funding
landscape on the number of public
companies in edtech
the number of growth companies and
that's all changing especially this year
right which is great
um but at the time you know that was
something i really wanted to focus on
and what i did coming at the other end
but getting there
yes like crazy journey worked at a
marketing software startup
worked at time hop the uh the social
media nostalgia app
worked like you know all over the place
really in all kinds of functions
um but you know i think every step along
the way
i knew it deep in my uh knowledge that i
wanted to remain in in tech
um i loved working closely with with
engineers and building products
um and with early stage founders so it
was really
concrete in that um in that area and
then as time went on
realized that i was most inspired by
working at a company with a strong
mission
um and so so the decision for instance
to work out pluralsight
was part of that you know i wanted to
become more of a sector expert
i wanted to understand what it was like
at a later stage company in the tech
sector
um and and how the uh how the businesses
differ there so sort of
you know longer than that but that
that's the gist of it in a way
i i have to learn a little bit about the
the education
sector in order to really grasp what are
you doing at the gsb and
what your where your passion lies
because it sounds like
you fell in love with edtech and with
finding
you know a balance between the right
business model to a high impact
opportunity to really help people
obviously through your experience with
africa but it sounds like it's it's
deeper than that talk to me a little bit
about this dissonance between finding
and finding a good business model for a
high
impact or social good company
sure sure so i you know to take a step
back um
looking at this problem through the lens
of how we make investments at gsv
you know first and foremost we always
say that the greatest returns
on the fund will come from the companies
with the greatest
impact and return on education right and
so these are the companies that are
going to reach
the largest number of learners or they
will be lowering the cost of education
right resulting in being able to access
more learners
and they're having their their strong
efficacy
with whatever product or service that
they're offering so
improved um improved outcomes for
education
and so we're looking at companies
through those lens when we're making
a decision on you know whether or not
we'll invest in them so what that
ends up you know when you're like
looking at very very early stage
companies and trying to decide
what's going to last what's going to be
a sustainable model what will
do all of those things or a combination
of them
is something that you know
the models have changed a lot in ed tech
so i think in the early days in k-12
there are a lot of
companies that were trying to sell
directly to schools you know fast
forward today
you see a lot of different creative
models where someone like
um you know a class dojo was free for a
number of years
and built up this enormous base of
teachers that
were absolutely obsessed with their
product and it was their their lifeblood
for communication you know outside the
classroom
with parents and students and then they
flipped on monetization last year you
know
and and then you know there so it's more
of a direct to consumer model in a way
even though it's in the classroom and so
they don't have to worry about these
really long institutional school sales
cycles
you know where there's only a limited
number essentially government dollars
that they're fighting over
so companies of today and ed tech on k12
and higher ed for instance are trying to
come up with more creative models um
you know things like course course hero
for instance is a
check competitor and they are a
marketplace of student resources so once
again you know
going straight to the learner um versus
going and
creating a university partnership on the
enterprise learning side
there's this is something i believed in
for a long time but
adult learners that cost of learning
yes there's always going to be an
individual cost as as life goes on but
the reality of today is that we are all
going to need to become
lifelong learners you know whether you
understand that now or not we're going
to constantly need new skills we're
going to constantly be changing jobs
and probably working longer than any
other
moment in history and so i would like to
see and there is a
belief and understanding now that
company should take on a lot of that
cost of retraining their employees
over time as well so there are a lot of
business models now focused on
on having the the company pay for their
employees education whether that's
in-house because they're going to stay
or like a plural site for instance or a
coursera or it could be someone like
guild education that's
providing um that's paying for their
frontline workers to earn
college degrees or skills certificates
which is pretty incredible and those
employees
i just had a a fascinating class at the
at
the graduate school of engineering a
product management class where actually
we were
working with target and i was the only
stanford student there
we had somebody from amazon from
microsoft from from google
and because they were coming in for
external training to do
to shift their priorities within the
company i believe some of them are
moving from engineering to product
management
and all of a sudden i find myself
working with people that are you know 10
15 years older they have all sorts of
different experiences
and combined learning i think obviously
i'm getting much more
excited and emotional when i think of
you know companies that are doing it for
the frontline workers to get college
degrees
and something like that but but but it's
it look it really looks like the world
is changing to what you were saying
what are some bigger problems that that
we are still thinking of today in terms
of education whether it's accessibility
it's you know information dissemination
what are some of those big picture
things that we still haven't figured out
yeah great question also love that love
that story um i think that the
another thing just as a quick aside that
i think will be huge is
how do we bring together learners of
different ages
and when you think about adult learning
age has been such a
construct in the past and really like a
lot of companies are experimenting with
adult learning by creating cohorts of
different age learners so i love that
idea
um so so so the
sorry i just lost track of the the
bigger the bigger i was getting excited
the bigger question are they thinking
yes i like i could go off on somebody's
entrance
it's because you're so passionate about
these ideas
or just you know rambling on um so the
so a couple of things so i mean when you
look at the us
for instance you know our levels of
um literacy and numeracy for college
graduates
have not been improving over the last
like 25 years
the the actual graduation levels have
been improving right and so there's been
a huge focus
in the us over the past few let's say
you know presidencies to increase
graduation rates are not about an 88
national level but there are you know
the the actual outcomes of a college edu
or a high school education are not there
so you know when you're thinking about
what problems need to be solved so
that's an enormous one
is is the actual um you know efficacy of
education
and outcomes there and it's really hard
to change the curriculum and to change
the system um but we're you know the
us's education levels are falling behind
many other countries in the world and so
if you're thinking about something
domestic like that's definitely a huge
issue and
and then of course that problem applies
to any potentially like emerging country
as well
where you just have an enormous number
of learners and so you're obviously not
going to have
the the right number of teachers that
are that are
able to see drive those outcomes either
potentially so that's
that's a big one for sure the other one
in higher education
you know we're going to be over doubling
the number of college
age students uh in the next 10 to 15
years
and there just aren't enough
institutions in the world
uh that have the capacity to uh to
educate the number of college age
students
that's in another way that's happening
here
uh just the world population growth you
know there's they're just going to be
uh an enormous number of of people of
that age level
and and so in terms of traditional
institutions you know you can't
you can't spend up a college overnight
um
you can't you know when you think about
things like accreditation which is a
huge obstacle in higher
ed innovation in the us um so making
sure that students are getting credit
for the courses that they're taking you
know there are a ton of hurdles there
it's an archaic system
uh that stifles a lot of innovation but
then you know and then internationally
same issue so one thing that's it that
we need to
to deal with and think ahead for which
you know companies like coursera and
others are doing is
you know how can we create online
programs that
maybe aren't for full degrees but
there's still
skills based potentially certifications
that have the branding that are
recognized by employers there needs to
be a shift on the employer side to
accept these new types of trainings and
we need to find a way to educate um that
group of call
you know traditionally college age
learners um coming down the road
and then the enterprise i think i've
mentioned it already but just thinking
about how do you
map the skills within your organization
understand the gaps
and then help up and up and reskill
which is there's a lot a lot of like a
hot conversation around right now and
everyone knows they need to do it but
actually
figuring it out is very difficult
especially in roles that aren't
um you know that have
more of an emphasis on soft skills or
things that are historically
hard to measure it's it's tough to
figure out
how to handle those tests i have to say
that you know i've done i've done quite
a few of these episodes one of the
things that inspires me most
across these episodes is when i meet
people that are they're just truly
passionate and curious about what
they're doing
that it's that they're the position
there and it's not just because it was a
cool opportunity and just a nice jump
start but
but really they're following this
trajectory of following their passion
following their curiosity
it's something that i live by and that
that i've become more and more inspired
through this show that the
people that are really making a
difference are those that that are truly
following their passions and and
and things don't become easy but they
become doable and they become energized
and and i and i i'm learning so much
from just from this you know short 20
minute conversation
tell me a little bit about a girl
develop it you're on the
you're on the advisory board there what
what are you doing over there
and what is sort of their mission
because it sounds really phenomenal
yes girl developer is a non-profit
that's been around for a long time now
in almost 10 years and they've reached
over 100 000
adult learners primarily women they
provide free or low cost
introductory level courses in
programming
topics and now i've expanded a bit more
to things like digital marketing
and and a few others um it's really
incredible i mean the goal
is to create an environment where adult
learners
you know i is intended originally for
women but it's really open to anyone
can learn in a judgment free space you
know
if they have been stuck in um
you know maybe just a pretty average
role for the last
10 15 20 years maybe they have a degree
maybe they don't
i mean really we have learners of all
ages they can come to girl development
they can say i'm curious about unity
development
i'm curious about devops you know i'm
curious about
javascript um i i maybe i heard about it
on a podcast maybe i heard about it you
know from a friend
um but i have no idea where to even
start i'm embarrassed that i don't even
know the right questions asked
um and they can come and take a course
and then and then start to
um create a new career trajectory from
there so really incredible there are
volunteer instructors
who are also paid time for teaching the
classes
and yeah it's really just an amazing
amazing non-profit and it's really fun
story how i got involved i met an
entrepreneur named brendan jenn
in january last year so we've only known
each other for about a year
um you know we did it wasn't the right
fit for an investment but her and i
really hit it off and
have become kind of thought partners and
friends and so she asked me to get
involved this summer
and um it's been yeah it's been a blast
we had a mini conference
we got unity involved to teach a course
and sponsor it and unity's um
a partner of gsv so it's just amazing to
see how the education ecosystem
you know everybody really plays together
and supports one another
yes it sounds it sounds phenomenal and
thank you for all the work that you're
doing both
with the gsb but also on these advisory
roles and for teaching it for teaching
dance i think that's a i i'm still i
i'm still oh to take oh to take the
social dance class that i'm supposed to
uh one day hopefully i'll get to do
touchy feely as well at the gsb but for
now i'll do the social dance class
test three words that you would use to
describe yourself and and
thank you for being so generous with
your time here
sure um great question this is very
difficult
um so i i mean i think the two
the two more obvious ones if you will
um i would say you know number one just
optimistic
and that's that's just you know for
better for worse
part of my dna um i
you know yeah and we're i think that's
anyone that's working
in an early stage startup anyone that's
just constantly trying new things like
you you kind of have to be and
you want to see things come to life and
yeah so that's a big one
um and
and then i hear this one a lot so i
guess i could say
it's maybe not self-described but um
and you know energetic so really like i
tried to definitely bring
energy to everything i do but it's true
it's something i realize over time and
the longer and longer you're in the
workforce and then
you know maybe um increasingly difficult
roles or more responsibility etc like
the the energy you put out into the
world is is how you're going to see
um that's going to reflect on others and
really kind of kind of change the mood
of a team you're working on
and your own self and so it's something
i focus on a lot
um and then i guess the last one would
be so maybe somewhere around
uh so i used to also teach kids
creative movement in shelters in new
york for nine years with another
non-profit so
dance but it was more creative movement
and i
kind of love this idea but not just
exactly creativity but somewhere around
like creativity fluidity where you know
no matter
what's coming at you you're able to kind
of make something out of it
feel something from it adapt like
something along the lines of that uh and
and so maybe it's more of a like a dance
move you're like living with a dance
move
um somebody some concept around there
but
i love that i attribute a lot of my
optimism
and my you know my the effect
the fact that i'm energized whenever i
something changes or whether whenever
i'm tackling a challenge
to the fact that i participated in a lot
of high school musicals
when i was back in high school that was
uh that was one of my favorite hobbies
because it was all about it was all
about interchanging ideas and then
you know and then the bridge would fall
from the stage
nobody because somebody pushed it by
accident and you have to now respond to
it
and have fun with it so i yes i
attribute a lot of that to that test
thank you so so much
this was wonderful thank you for the
inspiration it was great thank you
michael that's awesome and
one day we'll uh we'll put together
musical and sf together
100.
you